okay Larry Kudlow is with Fox Business
he said we are fighting for The Souls of
America for the soul of America we are
fighting for this very soul of this
great country and there's no better way
to do it than to compare the Ultra Blue
State of California versus the ultra Red
State of Florida California had some of
the hardest coveted lockdown measures
while Florida was among one of the first
states to reopen way back in May of
2020. California's economy has a 7.9
percent unemployment rate Florida is
below 5 percent California has a 13.3
percent top income tax rate Florida does
not have an income tax California has
amongst the biggest homeless population
in the country though it has only 12
percent America's population California
has one quarter of America's homeless
let me read that one more time even
though California only has 12 percent of
America's population California has a
quarter 25 percent of America's homeless
Florida is America's free estate
according to Cato Institute survey
number one in fiscal Freedom number one
in educational Freedom Cato dubs
California one of the least free states
and flat about dubs it the most crony
estate in the Union
New York Post columnist Kylie Smith says
again the most cronyiest state in the
unit cronius means people who are able
to buy politicians in that state to get
any agenda they want to get past it Adam
your big Larry Kudlow guy what do you
think about what he has to say about
this yeah I actually you know he's on
Fox Business he was
um at one point for a brief stint for
like less than a year Trump's economic
advisor is on his Council look there you
you talked about being a Wordsmith
earlier about the New York Times uh
Larry Kudlow did some wordsmithing here
especially stats or wartsmith
can I you call stats wordsmithing
can I say my point but but you called
would you call it Smith
I'm asking you a question did I get can
I say my point we're usually ask me
what's my point yeah I'm about to get to
my point I'm sorry I'm talking about the
stats tell me tell me here's my note
since you so rudely interrupted sir
fellas I said he's right but it's over
dramatic as an example here's my problem
with him yeah the ultra Red State of
Florida are you willing to say that
Florida is ultra red but by the way
today Texas isn't even ultra rare hear
me out today today many people would say
Florida's more red than Texas today many
people would say Florida and Texas have
switched in the last 18 months I don't
agree with that however
he may have been saying the government
is ultra red
point I think look as someone who has
lived in Florida's all life I think you
would be willing to say DeSantis has
done a good job here Marco Rubio Little
Marco Rubio Rick Scott those are both
Senators Republican Senators
buddy Alabama West Virginia Mississippi
states that no one's trying to live in
by the way sure when you move Valiant
you didn't think well what's going on in
West Virginia this month that didn't
happen I definitely didn't think
California New York either by the way
okay yeah exactly and the whole reason
look the numbers are true I'm not
debating that my whole thing was he's
right but it's dramatic it's a dramatic
effect This Is wordsmithing Here Yeah
the ultra Red State of Florida no this
is as purple as it gets it's voted uh
Clinton it's voted Obama it's voted
Trump it's voted by like
it goes either way however I think Larry
Kudlow has a major Point here I'm in
Florida I'm thankful living in Florida
it's the free estate in the goddamn
Union respect now let's talk to a
socialist over here from California okay
go back to your point yeah word smithing
stats I'm saying I didn't I didn't say
anything about the stats I agree with
the stats I said he's right and he's
true he's just over dramatic okay what
the over dramatic part is ultra red
states
exactly that's my point but the stats
tell a very and I agree with the stats
I'm not questioning the stats the stats
tell you exactly thank you to live in
Florida not California
you know what's do you know how many
people I've brought over here yeah and
they've stayed here for a week let's
just say okay I went to a restaurant the
other day whatever it's called the Blue
Moon something something where it's
right across Fort Lauder it's actually a
real nice restaurant I don't know what
it's called a nice restaurant You Go pay
lunches like you know uh uh you pay six
Blue Martini I don't know what it's
called nice restaurant underwater so I'm
there I'm leaving
and I'm getting the valet this 65 year
old lady's outside with a mask on
and she says I cannot believe the level
of irresponsibility of these people in
Florida how do you guys dare walk around
without a mask on and Dylan and Tico and
Cena are right next to me right and my
dad next to me I'm like really I said
ma'am I'm so sorry you feel that way
where are you from I'm from California
we are responsible that really what part
of California what do you know about
California I may know a little bit about
it where are you from Mission Viejo do
you know where that's at yeah I lived in
California 24 years and SoCal okay I see
you know what I've noticed about
Californians she said what I said I've
noticed in Californians whether you're
left or right you're miserable today why
because the ones who are on the left who
believe everybody should wear a mask
they think everybody's an idiot who
doesn't wear a mask and they're so
bitter and the ones on the right are so
bitter today because they don't want to
be forced to wear a mask California has
become bitter County and there's a lot
of people that are bitter like yourself
and nobody can make anybody happy in
California that's why a lot of people
man from your state are coming to States
like Texas and Florida whatever
what are the odds that she ran into you
in the valet line come on you can so
anyways what are your thoughts my
thoughts are hey you know I'm going to
take the positive spin here 12 of the
population lives in California we have
25 percent of the homeless population
we're overachievers I mean we're amazing
respect you know here's the thing at
what point do people with common sense
and intelligence understand that um it
doesn't have to continue to be this way
there are alternatives and it starts
with government and and you know what we
have the big election coming up here I
don't know if we haven't shot it or not
but it's easy to take shots at
California right now because we deserve
it and you don't see a lot of Hope
um he's also very good at getting the
attention he he said that he sees
Florida and South Florida replacing Wall
Street I just don't see that happening
do you I mean could you act actually it
would take this state a state like not
State as a state of Texas it would take
the state the current state of economy
in New York to stay like this for a
decade if it does it can happen but if
it changes if California and New York
change within the next eight years let's
just say Larry Elder announced yesterday
he's running for governor for California
I don't know if you heard that or not
last night larielle you know Larry
Albert who helped flip I think uh
conservative yeah black conservative he
knows yesterday he's running for
governor in the state of California
David Rubin David Reuben David yeah and
Larry Elders got a big following in the
state of California he's got a big
following period huh he's obviously
loved and hated because he's hated he's
got a lot of people that can't stand
what he stands for because he's a
conservative in the state of California
California is right now getting a lot of
people that are going to be running if
the politics in California New York
changes there's no way that's going to
be happening to Florida but if
California and New York State like this
for another decade he's absolutely right
Florida will be the next Wall Street so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]